Welcome back to another episode of
What's Up, Prof? Hello, Walter. Hi,
Martin. Are you doing well?
We're going to talk about Elijahs.
Three of them. Three of them, yes. Three
Elijahs and a remnant. Good. Let's talk
about it, but let's pray pray first.
Our heavenly Father,
thank you for bringing us together.
Thank you for giving us the opportunity
to have these discussions and
please enlighten our minds with the Holy
Spirit and guide us through all the
discussions, but also through our
studies. In Jesus' name, amen.
You know, Martin, after the last
discussion on what's happening in the
world,
and we see how crazy this world is.
We thought let's try and get some sanity
back and see what the three Elijahs can
tell us because they are the answer
to the chaos that we have in the world
today.
So, just to create that link that we
don't lose the spiritual connection.
You know what what you what you just
said,
how
would we be able to go through this
world and the time that we live in
if we didn't have this the the Bible?
Absolutely. And And the interesting
thing is
nobody wants it. No.
Nobody wants it, but it has the solution
to this entire problem. Everybody that I
speak to hates the circumstances that we
are in.
But, nobody wants to have the
alternative. It is absolutely amazing to
me. So, we need three Elijahs.
So, let's talk about them.
The first Elijah is, of course, the
typical Elijah.
And all the others must somehow be
connected to that message.
Plus, there are some interesting nuances
and hidden
uh factors that we must look at as well.
Well, we read in Malachi chapter 4,
"Remember ye the law of Moses, my
servant, which I commanded unto him in
Horeb for all Israel with the statutes
and judgments."
And then verse 5, "Behold, I will send
you Elijah the prophet before the coming
of the great and dreadful day of the
Lord, and he shall turn the heart of the
fathers to the children and the heart of
the children to their fathers,
lest I come and smite the earth with a
curse."
This is a reminder and a promise.
Yeah. Cuz it starts with remember.
So, what is it that we must remember?
The law of Moses, which I commanded him
in Horeb
with the statutes and the judgments.
So, the law's going to be very
prominent, right?
"And then I will send you Elijah the
prophet before the coming of the great
and dreadful day of the Lord." So, that
must be the final Elijah that will come.
Yeah, that's a prophetic one. That's a
prophetic one.
And then what is his job?
To turn the hearts of the fathers to the
children and the hearts of the children
to their fathers. So, I can I assume
that the hearts of the fathers and the
children are not in tune at the moment.
Definitely. They're not in tune.
Conflict.
And you have to get them back into tune.
The only way to do that is with the
Elijah message.
So, it has to come back to the Bible.
Yeah, you have to come back to to it and
you have to come back to the remember
bit.
Now, there's a certain commandment
that starts with remember. That's it.
The fourth one. The fourth one. It's the
only one that starts with remember. All
the others tell you something.
This one reminds you of something. So,
there's a lot of theology in these three
verses.
And we have to sort of work our way
through them because this is the only
solution
to the problem.
And you either take it or you leave it.
That's it. So, it doesn't help you
complaining about everything, but you
don't want to accept the solution.
Correct. Now, there's another point
that's interesting to me always.
You know, because by nature we are
rebellious.
And
I was probably more rebellious than most
and still have a rebellious streak in
me,
which can be used to advantage.
And even even the Lord can use it if
if the rebellion is in the right place.
Like Tyndale was called the Lord's
rebel.
He was the Lord's rebel because he stood
for a cause.
And he didn't give up. And he didn't
give up. And even when they put him on
the stake and strangled him and then
burned him,
he stood for what he believed, and this
is what we have to do.
Now,
if you were created by God, which the
Bible says you were,
then there is a desert a certain design
feature which God has placed in his
creation.
You were designed for specific purposes.
But, you were designed with a freedom of
choice.
And you were designed to live in harmony
with everyone
because in heaven there's no disharmony.
Now, what brings about harmony, Martin?
One-mindedness. Yes. You don't have to
have the same personality. That would be
exceedingly boring.
But, you have to have the same mindset,
the same understanding.
And it seems to me what people forgot
is what they have to remember.
Huh?
Cuz that's where it all started.
That's it. It started with something
that they forgot, and they have to be
reminded. And that's the job of the
Elijah. Yeah, and what's the whole
purpose of the plan of salvation?
It's to bring everything back in harmony
with how it was before the fall. Okay.
Now, if God designed you for a specific
purpose and a specific life, and he
designed you to be happy,
why are we so rebellious?
Because we want to listen to the enemy
of God rather than to God. And it
doesn't matter what field you touch,
man is rebellious.
If it says there in the beginning, "I
give you every seed-bearing plant on the
face of the whole earth and every tree
with fruit on it, and it shall be yours
for food." Man says, "No, I don't want
this. I want something else."
100% the opposite. I want 100%
nothing of this fruit-bearing plants and
seeds. I only want the other.
And if God says, "Remember the Sabbath
day to keep it holy. Six days shall you
labor and do work, but the seventh day
is the Sabbath." Man says, "I
don't want it. I'm going to do something
else."
Any day but that day. Anyone. We have to
keep all days. Anything but that day.
Isn't it interesting? This is how human
beings are.
So, this is what
what rebellion gone wrong actually
implies, right?
Okay. So, let's move on otherwise we can
talk forever.
And one last point here,
either they come back into harmony, the
fathers and the children,
or there's a curse. Yeah. And this
That's your choice.
There's no middle way. There's no
sitting on the fence.
No, it's either this or that.
That reminds me of the Laodicean
message.
You're either hot or you're cold.
That's it. The middle way you get spewed
out. It's the same. You're either
with Christ or against him. Yes. You
cannot be oh um I'm in the middle. Yeah.
But, the honest is your choice. If you
don't want to be there, then that is
your choice. You won't be there.
Just another thing. If you're on
Christ's side, then you do what he says.
There's no I I do certain things and ah
he didn't actually mean the other one.
Yes, but the point is you have to get to
the point
where the mindset of Christ becomes your
mindset. Otherwise, you're going to be
unhappy. Yes, because then even if you
do what he says, you'll be unhappy if
it's not his mindset. Correct. You know,
there were many things as I struggled
through from atheism to
to a believer where I said, "Well, I
don't want it this way."
But, it's going to be that way.
That's it. Whatever the subject is, can
be whatever. It can be marriage, can be
your diet, can be whatever. I don't want
it that way. I want it this way.
And then you have to think it through
because if God said it's going to be
this way,
then I must first get to the point where
I realize that his way is going to be
better. That's it.
But then I have to ask myself, why is it
going to be better?
I have to mull my way through it.
And once I get to the point where I
understand it
and say, well, that actually makes
sense. It's going to be better this way.
Then
then it becomes a pleasure.
Otherwise, it's going to be a war. It's
always like that. You have to accept
that his way is the best.
And you know what?
Whenever you've got these dark clouds
that are over you the whole time,
whenever you decide that God's way is
the best, that cloud those clouds
disappear. Yes. But we are so
rebellious, we don't want those clouds
to to disappear.
We don't even know how rebellious we
actually are.
So, let's have a look at this first
Elijah. It was a time when Israel,
the northern tribes, were incredibly
apostate.
And Ahab was ruling, and Ahab was
married to Jezebel. Now, there you have
a whole typology in itself.
Because when you pick it up in
Revelation,
you find that Jezebel plays an important
part.
And Jezebel is of course the one that
deals in scarlet and purple.
Now, a woman stands for a church.
So, there's this typology of this church
who has purple and scarlet
and deals with these. So, she's a
merchant.
Right?
She's not just a church, she's a
merchant. And if you pick it up in
Revelation chapter 18, you'll see that
Babylon is in charge of the merchants of
the world. Because when Babylon falls,
the merchants weep and wail.
So, it's an illicit relationship
typologically between the kings of the
world and the church.
And she leads the people into sun
worship. Mhm.
Now, that's what the literal Jezebel
did.
So, the antitypical Jezebel will do the
same thing. Exactly.
And the antitypical Jezebel, just like
the typical Jezebel,
is in conflict with Elijah.
And she persecutes him.
And Elijah actually runs for his life
from this Jezebel,
even though his message slaughters the
priests of Baal.
Interesting, right? Very interesting.
Yeah.
So, we have to look at this. So, Elijah
the Tishbite,
who was of the inhabitants of Gilead,
said unto Ahab, "As the Lord God of
Israel liveth, before whom I stand,
there shall not be dew nor rain these
years, but according to my word."
No dew nor rain. Now,
what is that in the spiritual sense?
No
um spiritual
uh
the Bible and the Holy Spirit.
Yes, there'll be no
rain. There'll be no former rain, there
will be no latter rain. The the Holy
Spirit will have been sidelined.
Mhm.
Until there is a certain change that
takes place.
And the change that has to be
done or the change that has to take
place is the Baal mindset must be
removed. Mhm.
It cannot just be put on ice, it must be
destroyed. The Baal mindset must go. It
must die. Mhm. It must be killed.
Mhm? That's it. That's the only way.
Otherwise, it will take over again.
There can be no rain, there can be no
dew
as long as Baal mindset prevails.
Okay?
And the word of the Lord came unto him,
saying, "Get thee hence, and turn thee
eastward, and hide thyself by the brook
Cherith,
that is before Jordan. And it shall be
that thou shalt drink of the brook, and
I have commanded the ravens to feed thee
there."
So, basically, he is sent into the
wilderness.
Elijah is sent into the wilderness, and
the bottom line is
God will take care of him. His bread and
his water will be sure.
And God did that.
And if we drop to verse seven, "And it
came to pass after a while that the
brook dried up because there had been no
rain in the land."
So, even the brook dried up. So, God
made another plan. He didn't leave
Elijah destitute. But if you must put
yourself in Elijah's shoes, at that
moment when the brook dried up,
I don't think he was very positive. No,
he was thinking, "Now what?" Right?
Yeah. It's an issue of faith. That's it.
But God takes care of him, so he sends
him to the widow of Zarephath.
And the word of the Lord came unto him,
saying, "Arise, get thee to Zarephath,
which belongeth to Zidon, and dwell
there. Behold, I have commanded a widow
woman there to sustain thee."
There's also another interesting
typology.
Mhm.
And if you take the words of Jesus,
there were plenty of widows in Israel in
the days of Elijah, but the Lord sent
them to none of these.
So, in other words, it's talking about
the church.
Church.
So, he was safer
with a widow woman.
Now, a widow is one that has lost her
husband, right?
So, basically, it was safer in some ways
for Elijah
to be amongst those that had lost their
connection with Christ whilst still
actually proclaiming that they were part
of it. Mhm. Mhm.
Okay, yeah.
And uh I don't know, in my in my own
experience, I have found this to be very
true.
The ones that bite you the most are the
widows of Israel.
Yeah.
They bite you the most, right?
They they take you to court, they uh try
to sideline you, they ban you, they
let's not go there. Let them have their
It's it's somehow safer
with a widow woman Yeah. than with the
widows of Israel. Israel.
Now, just on that point, there were
plenty of widows in Israel.
In other words, Martin, do you think
there are many in the church that have
lost their connection with Christ?
I'm sure of it. But they have a lot to
say, don't they? Mhm.
The more they have lost their connection
with Christ and the more they have
linked up with the Baal, Mhm. the more
they have to say. Yes, and the more they
think they are doing the will of God.
Yes.
And uh censoring seems to be a way to
go. So, only certain people may stand on
the pulpit, only if of course they have
permission to stand there on the pulpit.
Although even our manual says that if
you are ordained, then you're allowed to
speak. Mhm.
But let's leave it at that. This just an
interesting typology.
And so, he arose and went to Zarephath.
And when he came to the gate of the
city,
behold, the widow woman was there
gathering of sticks.
And he called to her and said, "Fetch
me, I pray thee, a little water in a
vessel that I may drink."
Now, where did he come
to meet her? He met her at the gate.
Now, the gate is the place of judgment.
Already, we have the theme of judgment.
And the judgments are in the land
because it's not raining, right?
And so, "I pray thee, a little water in
a vessel that I may drink."
And as she was going to fetch it, he
called to her and said, "Bring me, I
pray thee, a morsel of bread in thine
hand."
Bread and
water.
And she said, "As the Lord thy God
liveth,
I have not a cake, but a handful of meal
in a barrel and a little oil in a cruse.
And behold, I'm gathering two sticks
that I may go in and dress it for me and
my son that we may eat it and die."
So, what was the condition of this
woman?
Poor.
Dreadful. Dreadful, right? She was
destitute.
And this is the kind of poverty
that you actually have to have, if you
look at the Beatitudes. Blessed are the
poor in spirit.
So, if you have this poverty, in other
words, this great spiritual need, Yeah.
Dependence. then God will fill it.
Dependence on God, yeah. Yes, then God
can supply it. If you have no need, Mhm.
then why should he supply it? If you
hand him a full cup, is he going to fill
it? No. It's full already, right? Even
if it's full of abominations.
You have to get rid of the it and empty
the cup before you can be filled with
anything useful.
So, it's interesting that he says to
her,
"Bring me
that little bit that you have."
And she actually does it.
That's interesting.
This is evangelism at its best.
She realizes that he has something
that she needs.
And she's willing to do it.
And Elijah said unto her, "Fear not and
go and do as thou hast said,
but make me thereof a little cake first,
and bring it unto me, and after make for
thee and for thy son."
Now, is that a challenge? Oh, for sure.
If you have to put that in reality
today,
Yeah.
will you, if you are on your way to sit
down for a meal,
and you don't have anything else? Yes.
Give that meal to somebody else. And
then you sit without anything. And
you've got children a child.
So, what did she need in order to do
that?
Faith.
Even it's a little bit of faith, right?
She was probably not too charmed.
But she did it.
Okay.
There were plenty of widows in Israel in
the days of Elijah, but the Lord sent
them to none of them, sent her to this
woman. This is evangelism.
For thus says the Lord God of Israel,
"The barrel of meal shall not waste,
neither shall the cruse of oil fail
until the day that the Lord sendeth rain
upon the earth."
That is an amazing promise.
Does it still apply?
Yes.
Okay.
So, the barrel of meal, the bread of
life, shall not waste, neither shall the
cruse of oil stands for Holy Spirit. The
Holy Spirit
fail until the day that the Lord sends
rain upon the earth. What rain are we
talking about?
The latter rain. We're talking about the
latter rain. If we put that into
layman's terms for
latter rain means when the gospel is
being accepted by m-
millions.
And it's going to happen.
And who's going to be the most receptive
here? The the widows of Israel or the
widows that have lost their connection
to Christ out there? Yes, the widows
that have lost the connection. So, the
Elijah message
is a message that goes up in a time of
great drought.
And there are some that realize that
they have a need,
and some that don't realize that they
have a need. And those that don't
realize have a need are often part of
the church.
That is so true. It's what I said, eh?
Because you think you affiliated or
you're inside of something doesn't
necessarily mean you're
saved.
No.
And then the promise was fulfilled, and
the barrel of meal wasted not,
neither did the cruse of oil fail,
according to the word of the Lord which
he spoke by Elijah.
So, the Elijah message will not fail.
It will do its work.
It'll do its work amongst the widows.
That's where it'll do its work.
That's it. And it won't be
going very well No. because it's still a
drought. Now, who's the one who gave
Elijah the most opposition?
Ahab and Jezebel. Ahab and Jezebel gave
him the most opposition.
And they're the church. Now, that's an
interesting typology. Ahab stands for
Israel.
That's uh
the rulers within the church.
And the illicit alliance that they have
or that he has with Jezebel
makes this combination rather toxic.
Is that like church and state also?
That's church and state. It's an illicit
arrangement.
So, eventually, of course, Jezebel kills
the prophets of God while she and her
proph- prophets worship Baal and
Ashtoreth.
Now, Ashtoreth was a female deity.
First Kings 18 verse 1, and it came to
pass after many days, and those many
days we will read in the book of James
was 3 and 1/2 years. Very interesting
that the New Testament tells us
it's 3 and 1/2 years.
The Old Testament doesn't tell you. No.
But the New Testament tells you exactly
how long it was, 3 and 1/2 years.
That the word of the Lord came to Elijah
in the third year,
saying, "Go, show thyself unto Ahab, and
I will send rain upon the earth."
And Elijah went to show himself unto
Ahab, and there was a sore famine in
Samaria.
And Ahab called Obadiah, which was the
governor of his house.
Now, Obadiah feared the Lord greatly.
And this is fascinating.
So, you have this great apostasy that's
going on.
Ahab is at the head of this apostasy,
but his chief governor fears the Lord.
Inside of the same house. Inside the
same house. So, can we learn some
lessons for our church out of that? We
have to because we going to get
discouraged if we don't listen don't get
this message. All right. So, when you
think about Ahab,
and when you
are
constantly confronting
Ahab, and Ahab is constantly hunting
you,
then think about Obadiah. Yeah.
I've met many Obadiahs,
and if it weren't for them, I could
probably have despaired by now.
But there's always an Obadiah. Yeah.
For it was so when Jezebel cut off the
prophets of the Lord
that Obadiah took 100 prophets and hid
them by 50 in a cave and fed them with
bread and water. We have this theme
constantly, your bread and water will be
sure.
Now, Martin, does that mean we only get
bread and water or is this a spiritual
application?
Definitely spiritual as well. Of course,
right?
Because if you take it spiritually, this
is a war going also on inside of the
church.
This is a major war going up on
in the church.
But Elijah goes and preaches to the
destitute widow.
That's it. He's busy with his job. He's
doing evangelism.
That's it. He's not hovering over the
churches.
No. He went into the wilderness,
and then he went to the widow.
And she was not a widow of Israel.
That was his job.
So, he's carrying on while
this will be sorted out by God. This
this is what God is going to do. And now
comes a point of confrontation.
And the confrontation is typical of what
will happen.
It'll happen to all the Elijahs,
including the final Elijah.
So, James tells us something about
Elijah. It says, "Elias was a man
subject to like passions as we are."
That's very comforting.
He also had some despair and
some working out with his um temper
sometimes.
Now, I wish I were you, Martin, because
then I would have none of the problems
that I have.
Your life is totally problem-free,
right?
Yeah, no. We can swap for a while.
You You made a comment earlier that I
don't sit with my hand in my hair there
all times. No,
that's one advantage that you have, yes.
And he prayed earnestly that it might
not rain.
And it rained not on the earth by space
of 3 years and 6 months. So, there you
have it. James tells us how long it was,
exactly.
Now, let's continue the story. So, Ahab
had been hunting for Elijah,
and he couldn't get hold of him.
Elijah was a slippery fellow.
God was taking care of him.
That's it.
Can we expect the antitypical Ahabs
to hunt the Elijahs? Constantly trying
to get rid of them. Constantly writing
little things here, looking for them,
trying to get them
off the podiums and off the pulpits and
all these kinds of things, but God
somehow protected him, right?
And I comes to the this confrontation.
And when Ahab saw Elijah, that Ahab said
unto him,
"Art thou he that troubleth Israel?"
So, what is the mindset
of this
leader in Israel? Who's the Who's the
problem? The people that's trying to do
the evangelism, that's trying to tell
the truth to people,
these conspiracy theorists according to
them. They're the problem, right?
Okay. But Jezebel's not a problem. He's
actually in bed with her.
Mhm. She's not a problem.
No, Jezebel is fine, and whatever
Jezebel does is fine, even if she kills
the prophets of God.
In other words, she is eliminating
the message that must go out. And the
message is confined to a cave.
That's horrendous.
But the prophets are being fed
in the cave. So, I think they've got
spirit of prophecy books and they're
reading. Exactly.
Do you think that's possible?
Definitely. And when the time comes,
those 50 prophets in the one cave and
the 50 prophets in the other cave will
come out and will take part in the
Elijah message, right? Mhm.
All right. So, Ahab is a bit of a
problem and he thinks that if only he
could get rid of this pesky Elijah,
then his problems would be over. So, he
says to him, "Art thou he that troubleth
Israel?" And he gets a very straight
answer.
And he answered,
"I have not troubled Israel,
but thou and thy father's house, in that
you have forsaken the commandments of
the Lord and thou hast followed Balaam."
Does that message apply today?
Definitely.
Mhm? You see, that's what what we
mentioned earlier.
People are
thinking they're doing the service to
God,
but they are the actual troublers of
Israel.
So, when we read the text in Malachi, we
had the reference to the law of God
and then the Elijah that would come.
Now, here's the first Elijah, is there a
reference to the commandments of God?
That's where the problem lies. That's
where the problem lies. And they're not
only ignoring the commandments of the
Lord,
they're following the dictates of
Jezebel.
Exactly. Because Ahab is not stopping
Jezebel from doing what she's doing.
He's not putting his foot down and say,
"Hey, Jezebel, what are you doing?"
So, we have the same problem today.
So, you have forsaken the commandments
of the Lord, that's one thing,
but you followed Balaam.
So, if we look at some of our situations
in the world, if we look at the style of
worship, the music,
uh the dancing that's coming in,
and the type of preaching, the emotional
preaching, the Willow Creek type
preaching, emergent type theology,
uh isn't that Bale worship?
Definitely.
Mhm? Yeah. It's all prosperity.
Prosperity gospel, let your hair down.
Just don't don't bring the Elijah
message. It's too uncomfortable.
And it's a conspiracy to constantly
attack Jezebel. Mhm.
Mhm.
I mean, after all, she means well. Yeah.
Doesn't she?
So, verse 19, "Now therefore, send and
gather to me all Israel unto Mount
Carmel and the prophets of Bale, 450,
and the prophets of the groves, 400,
which eat at Jezebel's table."
So, there's a conglomerate of
individuals that sit at her table. Mhm?
And this confrontation is on Mount
Carmel. It's a whole ecumenical
get-together. Mhm.
Now, what is today on Mount Carmel?
It's a Baha'i temple.
Okay.
Now, Baha'i temple is the unity of all
religions. Wow.
And they have a document which they have
in this on display, which speaks about
the wronged one.
Now, the one who's wronged, of course,
is Lucifer.
Yes. Because he was thrown out of
heaven. And the Baha'i has the greatest
representation at the United Nations,
which represents the kings of the world.
So, the kind of worship that is taking
place on Carmel today
is one of ecumenical unity of all
religions, one world religion,
which honors the wronged one.
Yeah. Isn't that interesting? So,
nothing has changed.
So, the Elijah message cannot change
either. The the issue remains exactly
the same.
And the the prophets of Bale were 450
and the prophets of the groves,
they worshiped Ashtoreth, the female
deity, 400.
So, the Bale prophets outnumbered the
Ashtoreth prophets.
And they all ate at Jezebel's table.
So, there is unity in diversity there.
That's
These at one table lets me think of
the Daniel
prophecy. All right. Now, if we look at
the groves today, Mhm.
Mother Earth,
that all the Earth worship
that we have in the world.
Yeah. Climate change is all is a Climate
change is nothing other than grove
worship. That's exactly what it is. And
they're sitting at Jezebel's table. Are
all the worshipers of the groves today
sitting at Jezebel's table? Definitely.
And can they be a part of any religion
and be part of these greenies? Yes. We
saw even the Pope with the Amazon
get-together, Papa Pachamama and all of
that.
All of these issues, they're all very
happy at the at Jezebel's table.
And then, of course, the Bale priests.
Now,
the Bale worship was very attractive.
And it's the type of worship that we see
in the Christian world today.
What we don't see
is absolute Bible-based preaching
anymore. Definitely not.
We don't see that anymore. It's all
emotional.
It has to be a feeling. It has to be a
feeling. So, they're all sitting at at
this table and enjoying themselves
while there is a crisis at Carmel. A
confrontation
is coming.
If we drop down to verse 14, Elijah said
unto them, "Take the prophets of Bale,
let not one of them escape." And they
took them and Elijah brought them down
to the brook Kishon and slew them there.
Now, this is after the confrontation
where the prophets of Bale
had an opportunity to show that their
sacrifice would be consumed with fire.
And Elijah had the same opportunity.
They danced and screamed and sang and
cut themselves and all of these things
all day long until they were exhausted.
And Elijah occasionally
uh was a little bit sarcastic.
He was. Yes, he was a little bit
sarcastic. He asked if they are if they
are deaf. Yes. Is he deaf?
Are they sleeping? It actually says he
you know, if you go to the original, it
actually says perhaps he's relieving
himself or he's on a long journey or
whatever.
But the simple prayer Mhm.
had to be preceded by a very simple act,
placing the original altar with the 12
stones on it. Mhm.
Now, 12 stones,
12 patriarchs, 12 apostles.
The hearts of the fathers, the hearts of
the children that have to be reconciled.
It's one religious system. It's one
mindset. And it's so simple.
And the interesting thing is when he
said, "How long halt ye between two
opinions?"
They answered him not a word.
Deathly silence. Don't we have the same
thing today?
Perfectly the same. It's it's amazing.
But eventually, the Elijah message
manages to slay all
the priests of Bale.
Now, Jezebel
will be
infuriated.
And Elijah said unto Ahab, "Get thee up,
eat and drink, for there is a sound of
abundance of rain."
So, Martin, when does this rain come?
After the slaying of the prophets. So,
the
Bale message must be exposed.
Expose the wickedness of the man of sin.
Isn't that what he must do?
And once it is exposed,
so that people can make clear decisions,
then it's time for rain.
So, Ahab went up to eat and to drink.
And Elijah went up to the top of Carmel
and he cast himself down upon the earth
and he put his face between his knees
and he said to his servant, "Go up now,
look towards the sea."
And he went up and looked and said,
"There's nothing."
And he said, "Go again."
Seven times.
Seven is the number of God, right?
Do you think he had to exercise some
faith here?
Exactly.
It's the same as Naaman. He had to
uh
go into the water seven times as well.
Yes. So, he could have decided after the
fifth time, "This is not working."
Exactly. So,
can you feel you can relate to how seven
times, here by the fifth and sixth
times, you
you're just tired. You don't want to
anymore.
Seven times.
And it came to pass at the seventh time
that he said, "Behold, there arises a
little cloud out of the sea like a man's
hand.
And he said, "Go up.
Say unto Ahab, 'Prepare thy chariot and
get thee down that the rain stop thee
not.'"
And it's fascinating that he runs ahead
of the chariot.
So, God gives him divine power.
And he runs ahead.
Did it save Ahab?
No.
Did it make him think? Yes. Probably
yes, right?
But he was so hooked up with Jezebel
that he couldn't let go. That's very
sad.
Can we expect that many in leadership
are so hooked up with Jezebel
that they will actually miss the point
of the latter rain?
Sadly, yes.
Now, I'm not trying to be facetious
here. No. I'm just trying to be
realistic. This is what the situation
is.
And when the shaking comes,
we will have to be prepared for
whatever the consequences will be. It
will be a very sad state of affairs.
It will. There will be some,
unfortunately, that won't accept the
message. They won't accept the message.
Prophets and Kings, page 156. Again and
again, Elijah sent his servant to a
point overlooking the Mediterranean
to learn whether there were any visible
token that God had heard his prayer.
Each time the servant turned returned
with the word, "There is nothing."
The prophet did not become impatient or
lose faith, but continued his earnest
pleading. Six times
the servant returned with the word that
there was no sign of rain
in the brassy heavens.
Undaunted,
Elijah sent him forth once more, and
this time the servant returned with the
word, "Behold, there arises a little
cloud out of the sea like a man's hand."
This was enough.
Elijah did not wait for the heavens to
gather blackness, and that small cloud
he beheld by faith
an abundance of rain. And he acted in
harmony with his faith, sending his
servant quickly to Ahab with a message,
"Prepare thy chariot and get thee down
that the rain stop thee not."
So, is there a typological message here?
Definitely.
Don't give up. Don't get discouraged.
Seven times, not six.
Six is the number of Baal.
So, if you stop there, then you will
stay with Baal. Stay there.
So, let's look at early writings and see
if we can get the the parallels. Soon
our eyes were drawn to the east
for a small black cloud had appeared
about half as large as a man's hand,
which we all knew was the sign of the
Son of Man.
We all in solemn silence gazed on the
cloud as it drew nearer and became
lighter, glorious, and still more
glorious until it was a great white
cloud.
The bottom appeared like fire. A rainbow
was over the cloud,
while around it were 10,000 angels
singing a most lovely song, and upon it
sat the Son of Man.
His hair was white and curly and lay on
his shoulders, and upon his head were
many crowns.
His feet had the appearance of fire. In
his right hand was a sharp sickle, in
his left a silver trumpet.
His eyes were as flame of fire, which
searched his children through and
through.
Then all faces gathered paleness, and
those that God had rejected gathered
blackness.
Then we all cried out, "Who shall be
able to stand?
Is my robe spotless?"
Then the angels ceased to sing, and
there was a time of awful silence when
Jesus spoke.
"Those who have clean hands and pure
hearts shall be able to stand. My grace
is sufficient for you."
At this our faces lighted up, and joy
filled every heart. Then the angels
struck a note higher and sang again,
while the cloud drew still nearer to the
earth.
Is this biblical?
Oh, for sure.
It's like reading Revelation. That's it.
And if you take this cloud with a faith
that Elijah
had put towards in knowing that God is
coming to
bringing this rain and saving them. Yes.
You've got the same with this in the
message.
is essential. This is the gathering.
So, the Elijah message
must slay the prophets of Baal.
There must be a confrontation. There
must be a choosing of sides.
And you're either for it or against it.
How long halt thee between two opinions?
And Ahab had made his bed with Jezebel,
and he was going to lie in it. And his
entire posterity
was destroyed.
Yeah.
All right. So, there was the typical
Elijah. We have a very typical message.
We have a very typical confrontation.
It's a confrontation between two types
of worship.
And the commandments of God and
obedience to God is pivotal in the
exercise.
It is a message against an alliance, an
illicit alliance between a king and a
woman. Mhm. Mhm.
Between the church and the state.
That is the message of the first Elijah.
So, let's go to the second Elijah.
John the Baptist is the second Elijah.
Now, you know, people were superstitious
and thought maybe he was a resurrection.
But he wasn't.
He wasn't a resurrection. It was the
message that was important.
Yeah, he wasn't an incarnation. No.
John the Baptist. Now, also a very
interesting difference between this
Elijah,
John the Baptist,
and the first Elijah
is that the first Elijah
had a message that was accompanied by
numerous miracles.
This Elijah, the second one, had no
miracles.
He just had a message.
That's very important. And this message
is the same as the first Elijah,
but without the works because the works
were already done there.
That's a good point.
So, let's go to Luke chapter 1 verse 15.
And he shall be great in the sight of
the Lord,
and shall drink neither wine nor strong
drink,
and he shall be filled with the Holy
Ghost even from his mother's womb. You
know, that verse is really loaded,
Martin.
He shall drink neither wine nor strong
drink,
and he shall be filled with the Holy
Ghost even from his mother's womb.
Now, that was literal. Mhm.
So, he was a Nazarene. He never had to
touch any of the wine or any strong
drink.
But he was filled with the Holy Ghost
from his
mother's womb. In other words, from
inception. Mhm.
The final Elijah,
from the moment that he is conceived,
appears on the
world stage, he will be filled with the
Holy Ghost.
And once the Holy Ghost has confirmed a
message, no subsequent message can undo
what has been confirmed.
So, the pillars of Adventism are to
stand until when?
Till the end.
Till the end. Will there be attempts to
tear down the pillars?
Oh,
lots of it. Lots of it.
All right. So, we have a number of
things here. He's a literal
vegetarian
because he eats locusts and wild honey.
And the locust is plant-based according
to the spirit of prophecy. So, that must
have been the locusta bean, which is the
carob bean,
which was the diet of the
not-so-wealthy.
So, he had a plain diet.
Matthew 11 verse 13. And all the
prophets and the law prophesied until
John.
And if you will receive it, this is
Elias that was for to come. So, Jesus
very plainly
says that John the Baptist is Elijah.
Not the literal Elijah, the first
antitypical one.
Okay. And all the prophets and the law.
So, we have the law and the prophets
again.
Prophesied until John.
Now, when Jesus was on the Mount of
Transfiguration,
who appeared? Elijah
and Moses. Moses. Moses stands for the
law.
And Elijah stands for the testimony to
the law
and to the testimony.
If they speak not according to this
word,
there's no light in them. So, whatever
they spoke,
stands.
Stands, right?
And if the children have digressed from
that,
then they must turn their hearts to the
fathers and the fathers to the children,
and they must come back into harmony
with the law and the prophets. That's
it.
The law and the testimony, is that also
a feature of the remnant? Yes.
100%.
So, isn't it beautiful how it's all
linked together?
You know, who could have thought this
up? That's it. That's it. Only God. Only
God can think this up. And that shows
you how important it is to also not
discard the Old Testament. No.
Because
all
the truth is already in there.
Correct. So, Jesus quite plainly tells
them that
this John the Baptist has an Elijah
message.
So, we need to study again what it was
all about.
John 1:21 and they asked him, "What
then? Art thou Elias?" So, they're
asking John the Baptist straight out,
"Are you Elias?"
And he says, "I'm not."
So, was Jesus lying or was Jesus talking
typologically? Typologically.
Absolutely. There's no other way to
interpret it.
"Art thou that prophet?" In other words,
"Are you the Messiah?"
He answered, "No."
The next day, John sees Jesus coming
unto him and says, "Behold the Lamb of
God which takes away the sins of the
world."
So, this is his job.
Part of the Elijah message that he has
is, "Behold the Lamb of God
that takes away the sins of the world."
Now, what is sin, Martin? Transgression
of the law.
So, are we back to square one? 100%. We
had it in the previous one.
The commandments, that's the reason why
everything was happening. They didn't
get here to the commandments.
All right. And here you have the law and
the prophets and here you have
the one who is the cure for the sin
problem, for the transgression of the
law. Isn't it amazing that the churches
today,
those that follow the veil, seem to
believe that the commandments are not
binding.
Because they have to get rid of it.
Then they
all their their doings
is justified. Correct.
Then said he to the multitude that came
forth to be baptized of him,
"O generation of vipers,
who has warned you to flee from the
wrath to come?" Who's he talking to? To
the leaders of the church.
He's talking to the Pharisees.
Now, did the first Elijah have a
confrontation with the leaders? Yes.
Does the second one have a
confrontation? One, this makes me
nervous. Mhm. Mhm?
So, if you don't have a confrontation,
is there something wrong? You might be
on their side.
You might be on their side, right?
Oh, we have to be very careful here.
But, don't forget there's Obadiahs.
Ah, don't forget him.
If it weren't for him, we would despair,
right?
Okay. So,
this multitude comes and he calls them a
generation of vipers. That's pretty
strong language.
You see,
this language
makes me think that
people that always shout, "Don't You
must soften the message."
Yeah.
I don't see the prophets of God
softening messages. No. No, he calls
them a generation of vipers.
And then he tells them what their
problem is. "Bring forth therefore
fruits worthy of repentance and begin
not to say within yourselves, 'We are We
have Abraham to our father, for I say
unto you that God is able of these
stones to raise up children unto
Abraham.'"
So, don't become complacent because you
belong to a particular denomination. No.
Don't think you are saved because you
belong to the remnant church.
That's it. These stones
refer
to the heathen.
Absolutely correct. Now, remember the
the fig that was cursed? Mhm. It was a
presumptuous fig tree
cuz it was full of leaves, but it had no
fruit.
Whereas normally if it had leaves, it
should have had fruit, right? Cuz the
fruit become comes first in the case of
the fig. Now, it was in a grove and
there were many fig trees. Yes.
But, the others weren't presumptuous.
They had no leaves and therefore you
couldn't pretend that they would have
fruit.
Yeah, you didn't have You couldn't
expect fruit from them. Correct. And so,
they weren't cursed
because they weren't presumptuous.
They stand for the heathen.
They would eventually produce the fruit
that the presumptuous tree did not
produce.
So,
here we have a very similar situation.
He's He's now instead of
trees referring to stones.
Same symbol as you have rightly said.
Yeah, so he's standing there accusing
the leaders of the church that if you
don't do your job,
these people might start doing it. Ah,
so who's going to accept the message?
The widow.
Mhm? Exactly. The widow not of Israel.
Not of Israel.
And then, and now also the axe is laid
unto the root of the trees. Every tree
therefore which bringeth
not forth fruit is hewn down and cast
into the fire.
All right. So, let's ask ourselves a
question. Does this second Elijah come
into conflict with the leadership of the
church? Yes.
Very harshly. It's a It's a sad state of
affairs, right?
But, it's a reality. That's it. So, when
it does happen, should you be surprised?
No.
You should have the faith of Elijah.
Okay. We're We're on dangerous ground
here, Martin, but it's biblical. This is
the biblical ground.
For years, the Lord has been calling the
attention of his people to health
reform.
This is one of the great branches of the
work of preparation for the coming of
the Son of man.
John the Baptist went forth in the
spirit and power of Elijah
to prepare the way of the Lord and to
turn the people to the wisdom of the
just.
He was a representative of those living
in these last days to whom God has
entrusted sacred truths
to present before the people to prepare
the way for the second appearing of
Christ.
John was a reformer.
The angel Gabriel, direct from heaven,
gave a discourse upon health reform to
the father and mother of John.
He said that he should not drink wine or
strong drink and that he should be
filled with the Holy Ghost from his
birth.
Interesting, right?
For years, the Lord has been calling the
attention of his people to health
reform.
This is one of the great branches of the
work of preparation for the coming of
the Son of man. John the Baptist went
forth in the spirit and power of Elijah
to prepare the way of the Lord
and to turn the people to the wisdom of
the just. He was a representative of
those living in these last days
to whom God has entrusted sacred truths
to present before the people to prepare
the way for the second appearing of
Christ.
Now, if I go to the first Elijah,
the ravens brought flesh. Mhm.
But, later on, he only got bread. That's
it.
Mhm? So, he progressed. There was a
progression. This Elijah
was vegetarian from birth.
The antitypical one will have to be
the same. Yeah.
Is this a war in the church?
Huge. It's
It's a All right. Does the health
message uh pertain only to eating and
drinking or does it pertain to disease
and treatment of disease as well? All of
it. It's got everything to do with
health and lifestyle. Has Jezebel got a
health message? Yes. Does she have a
needle that she likes to insert? Yes,
and she's got a whole stack of drugs
that comes with it. Do we have a message
to counter that? Yep.
The simple elements of nature, clean
air,
good food,
the intelligent use of water, exercise.
It's much easier to take a needle.
Mhm?
Now,
if you have to choose sides there,
"How long halt you between two opi-
Let's not go there, Martin. Let's just
plant the seed and move on."
So, this is to prepare the way for the
second appearing of Christ.
You know what?
We are
I think
already in the drought.
Oh, we are in a serious drought.
And we are doing our job
to the widow.
Yes. That's our job.
So, we must start thinking, "How near is
all of this
to the second coming?" It must be very
close.
Though no miraculous deliverance was
granted John.
He was not forsaken. He had always the
companionship of heavenly angels who
opened to him the prophecies concerning
Christ and the precious promises of the
scripture. That's a beautiful promise.
So, as long as you cling to your Bible
and the spirit of prophecy, no matter
how daunting the circumstances,
if you cling to those,
then you'll get through it.
Even if you lose your head. That's it.
These were his stay
as they were to be the stay of God's
people through the coming ages.
To John the Baptist, as to those that
came after him, was given the assurance,
"Lo, I am with you all the days, even
unto the end."
God never leads his children otherwise
than they would choose to be led if they
could see the end from the beginning and
discern the glory of the purpose which
they are fulfilling as co-workers with
him.
Not Enoch, who was translated to heaven,
not Elijah, who ascended in a chariot of
fire, was greater or more honored than
John the Baptist, who perished alone in
the dungeon.
And to you it is given in the behalf of
Christ not only to believe on him, but
also to suffer for his sake. Philippians
1:29.
And of all the gifts that heaven can
bestow upon men, fellowship with Christ
in his suffering is the most weighty
trust and the highest honor.
Now, Martin, why was he beheaded?
Because he confronted Herod. Ah. Now,
the first Elijah, did he confront the
king?
Yes, Ahab. He confronted Ahab, right? He
was one of the leaders in Israel. Now,
Herod, wasn't he also the king of
Israel?
Yes. So, that was the state.
of Judah. He was the king of Judah,
right?
All right, so
there was an alliance between Herod, the
Herodians,
Mhm. and the Pharisees and the
Sadducees.
They didn't like each other.
No.
But when it came to the persecution of
Christ, they were of one accord.
They worked together. Yes. And Herod and
Pilate, who represents Rome,
they were at loggerheads in the
beginning, but when it came to the
persecution of Christ,
they became friends.
Yeah.
So, you need a common enemy. That's it.
And that common enemy is going to be the
Elijah.
And the kings
of the church
and the governor of Rome will make an
alliance and become friends.
It's a rather sad state of affairs. He
said, "It is not lawful
for you to be married to your brother's
Philip's wife."
So, God never recognized his wife
as the wife of Herod.
Mhm?
So, was there again an illicit
relationship between the king and a
woman?
That's it. Did the first Elijah have the
same thing? 100% the same.
All right. The first Elijah said, "It's
not I that am the trouble of Israel, but
you and your house, because you have
forsaken the commandments of God." The
commandments of God, generally speaking
of all of them. Yeah.
This one has a very specific commandment
that he's addressing.
Which one is that?
Adultery.
Adultery, the seventh commandment.
And the seventh commandment is a
commandment of relationship.
Yeah, right?
And they were breaking that commandment.
Now, there were two things that were
instituted in Eden.
And they both dealt with relationship.
Mhm.
What were they?
The Sabbath
and wedding. And marriage.
Sabbath and marriage, both relationship
commandments.
So, here we get a little bit closer
to the real issue. What are the
commandments all about?
They are about relationships.
Relationship between man and man and man
and God.
The first table, tablet,
had the rules and regulations for your
relationship with God.
Yeah.
And the second one, your relationship
with man.
And one of the most intimate of all the
relationships is ensconced in the
seventh commandment.
There was a problem.
It was a problem with Ahab as well.
Yep.
And here you have the same problem.
So, church and state are illicitly
together.
And the second Elijah warns against it.
Is his message well received?
No, he loses his head. Mhm.
So, when our people fraternize with Rome
and sit in ecumenical councils and even
chair
or sub-chair
ecumenical councils,
and you bring a message like this, will
it be well received? No, you just might
lose your head. Mhm. Now, who actually
instigates
the attack on this antitypical Elijah?
The mother. The mother. The mother. But
the mother has a daughter.
Mhm.
And the daughter is the one that dances
before the king.
Now, in this typology,
you have the kings Mhm. represented by
Herod.
You have the mother
with which he is wedded illicitly.
That's the same as Jezebel.
And she has daughters. Is there a church
that says that she will not suffer loss
of daughters? Yes. Or loss of children?
The Roman Catholic Church. It has
daughters, and who are those daughters
that she claims will return to her?
Everybody that falls into ecumenical
council with her. And Protestantism in
particular?
Mhm. Now, who's the one who's going to
dance before the king?
The daughter. The daughters. Mhm. Who's
going to ask for the head of John the
Baptist? Also the daughter.
But who informed the daughter to ask?
The mother. The mother. Is there heavy
typology in there? Definitely. Mhm?
This is fascinating. Now, who can think
that up? Only God. And it stands there,
so it will happen.
Yes. And he he actually
built it into literal relationships.
Yes.
With people with free choice.
That's just mind-blowing.
It's mind-blowing.
The Elijah message is so deep.
So, Martin, if God sees fit in the
second Elijah to become less generic
commandments and now hones in on a
commandment of relationship, which is
illicit,
can we expect fireworks from that? Yeah.
All right. Now,
what relationship stands even higher
than the relationship between man and
man and woman?
Huh? So, do you think that the
commandment of relationship could become
a factor?
Of
and authority. All right. So, that's the
relationship between God and man. That's
ensconced in the fourth commandment,
because only those two
were already instituted in Eden, right?
So, can we expect the final Elijah
to have a very specific confrontation
about a relationship commandment? Yes.
The fourth commandment?
That's the one that
is forgotten.
To sum up,
we're going to have a confrontation
between leaders that are in illicit
relationships
with women. Mhm.
Churches.
The first Elijah tells us who that woman
is, Jezebel.
The Bible in Revelation tells us
in the seven churches, in the middle
church, the church of the Middle Ages,
that there is a Jezebel.
It tells us that she leads God's people
into sun worship.
And that there is an illicit
relationship we see in the second
message.
It's going to come to the point when the
mother
incites the daughter to ask for the
head.
And some might lose their head.
Mhm.
And others
might be translated
as the first Elijah was.
Because that is the message. He was it.
He was translated, and so the
antitypical final Elijah will also be
translated. The interim one, which was
John the Baptist, lost his head.
Mhm.
Now, anybody who preached that
commandment or anybody who preached his
message
was also inclined to lose his head.
Mhm. Mhm.
And Rome was a very persecuting power
and was responsible for the loss of many
heads.
The final one has this hope to cling to.
Yes, yes. That he can be translated
without seeing death. But the
confrontation will be fierce, because it
will revolve around the commandments of
God, bail worship, and very specifically
the commandment of relationships.
So, before we
uh go into the details,
let us close off here and then discuss
the further events in
a next episode. Just one more thing.
In both the typical and John the Baptist
Elijah message, both of them had a lot
of faith.
Because John never saw Jesus when he was
in jail. No, he never saw him there. And
it's also interesting as you say,
the first Elijah had a moment of
despair.
The second Elijah had a moment of
despair as well.
Exactly.
Are you the one or do we expect another?
Although he just preached, "Behold the
Lamb of God takes away the sins of the
world." So, it's going to be tough.
Yeah. It's going to be very, very tough.
And there will be moments of despair.
But what has to carry you through
is your faith.
Seven times.
Amen. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father,
thank you for the Elijah message. We can
learn so much out of it.
May we carry gather strength
from the weakness of others.
May we gather
courage from cowardice.
And may we
gather faith and trust from treason.
Thank you, Lord, that we have these
messages. And thank you that there is a
promise attached to them.
And thank you, Lord, that the outcome
will be such
that those who stick to the message and
cling to the promises
can be called sons and daughters of God.
Thank you for this in Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen.